foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to this special report
where we take a look at the big events
that have shaped our world in the last
12 months I'm Angus Harvey and this is
the news
We Begin our broadcast with a story that
has dominated headlines this past year
Russia's invasion of Ukraine the war has
inflicted a terrible human toll plunging
Millions into an unrelenting conflict
dramatically upending International
politics and sparking turmoil in energy
markets around the world
perhaps the only thing scarier than a
war like this is the prospects of our
planet being ruined by climate change
however
on that front the news has been somewhat
better specifically as a result of this
crisis the global fight against climate
change
has accelerated in response to Putin's
attempt to use gas and oil as Weapons
Europe has doubled down on green energy
last year for the first time ever wind
and solar overtook gas nuclear or coal
as the continent's largest source of
electricity and analysts say that as a
result of the war Europe's timeline for
dishing fossil fuels has accelerated by
up to a decade
staying with the climate in the United
States a new law has committed hundreds
of billions of dollars of investment
into Renewables and electric vehicles
putting the country on track to getting
80 percent of its electricity for
carbon-free sources
by the end of this decade and in the
race to build more clean energy China is
way ahead of both Europe and the United
States the country is now installing
enough solar panels every day to cover
an area the size of New York's Central
Park
at the current rate China will reach its
climate targets years ahead of schedule
the energy revolution has arrived
Global fossil fuel emissions are now
predicted to Peak within less than two
years and the International Energy
agency says that wind water and sunshine
will become the planet's largest sources
of electricity by 2025.
to Global health where many countries
are still struggling in the aftermath of
the covid-19 pandemic less widely
reported is the news that last year
eight countries eliminated at least one
neglected tropical disease
top of that list Togo which became the
first country to eliminate four
of those diseases
including trachoma the world's most
common infectious cause of blindness
go Togo
today almost 600 million fewer people
require treatment for these diseases
than in 2010 it's thanks to the work of
tens of thousands of uncelebrated Heroes
of Public Health it means
that in just over a decade a significant
portion of humanity has been liberated
from a devastating burden of suffering
and from death
there's also hope on the horizon in the
fight against malaria
last year a new vaccine designed by the
University of Oxford was shown to be
safe and Incredibly effective four days
ago Ghana became the first country to
license That vaccine for distribution
Nigeria followed that up eight hours ago
both countries are now going to
vaccinate children under the age of
three
this is a world-changing treatment it
offers us genuine hope that we may
finally be able to eradicate
one of Humanity's biggest Killers a
Scourge that has plagued our species for
thousands of years
imagine if this was the news
that along with all of the usual death
and disaster and the vision we also got
to hear these the the stories of Hope
and healing
but not just another dog on a surfboard
the thing is this is the news these
these stories they're happening it's
just that we don't hear as much about
them but when you find them
world can suddenly feel like a very
different place
let's turn now to some environmental
news where pollution and degradation
continue to push Earth's ecosystems past
their breaking point however in the last
year Humanity has begun to respond
four months ago the countries of the
United Nations came together to agree on
a global Pact
protect 30 percent of the planet by 2030
and just weeks ago after nearly two
decades of negotiations
they agreed on the first ever
legal framework for regulation on and
protection of life on the high seas
the tides are beginning to turn here's
conference president Rina Lee announcing
what Greenpeace has called the greatest
conservation victory of all time ladies
and gentlemen
the ship has reached the shore
more good news for the environment since
the beginning of last year we've seen
the expansion of protected Waters around
the Galapagos the creation of an
enormous Marine Sanctuary west of
Australia
and a provisional agreement between
Canada's government and First Nations to
create the San Juan hatch quick huxigas
Marine protected area that will be
Canada's largest MPA that is just off
the coast of West Vancouver that's
that's less than 150 kilometers from
where we all are right now
last year Argentina created a national
park around one of its biggest saltwater
lakes and wetlands earlier this year
Ecuador created one of the largest
reserves in the Amazon in one of the
most biodiverse places on the planet
and last month
the largest river restoration project in
United States history kicked off on the
Klamath River led by the Europe people
of California
none of it is enough yes
but these are Big victories they show us
that destruction is not inevitable and
that nature will recover if we can just
give it the opportunity
this report just in now from our
political and social Affairs editor
last year saw some significant setbacks
for human rights most notably in the
United States where for many it feels
like intolerance and polarization are on
the rise
globally however it's a very different
story
since the beginning of 2022 countries
have abolished the death penalty six
countries have ended child marriage
four countries have banned conversion
therapy four countries have legalized
homosexuality and 11 countries have
actually strengthened Reproductive
Rights
that includes India
which passed a law guaranteeing access
to Safe abortion for every single woman
and Spain which also protected
transgender rights and became the first
country in Europe to provide paid
menstrual leave
oh and sorry I forgot to mention
Slovenia Cuba and Mexico all past
legislation on same-sex marriage and
adoption three times three times as many
countries Now Grant those rights to all
of their citizens compared to a decade
ago
the fight for equality continues
but progress is happening even if we
don't hear much about it
in the last year Humanity has moved
closer to a world where everyone is free
to choose
and Free to Love
on that note Let's cross now to some
more economic news uh many will have
missed last year's report from the
United Nations that India lifted
415 million people out of poverty
between 2006 and
2021. despite some of that progress
being set back by the pandemic that
still means that on average every day
for the last 16 years a soccer stadium
full of people escaped poverty the worst
kinds of deprivation that is one of the
greatest news stories of all time
krusner to our correspondent in the
field Angus Harvey to get some more uh
of these and some other stories from
around the world Angus over to you
thank you very much Angus well I'm here
in Brazil with the new ministry of
indigenous people is bringing much
needed food hope relief and Aid to the
country's indigenous communities they've
already deployed the military to remove
tens of thousands of illegal Miners and
restore Justice
Zimbabwe I'm here with the akashinga an
all-female army of wildlife ranges there
these uh women many of them are
survivors of domestic violence uh but
they have become formidable Warriors
after years in the field
uh that the military trainers say
they're more hardcore than a lot of the
world's Special Forces and they're
really changing the face of conservation
here and the other four countries where
they're operating uh they have hundreds
of their members out there now they're
uplifting their communities bringing
down poaching rates dramatically and
contributing to a huge Rebound in wild
animal populations
and finally in Bangladesh
where thousands of newly trained
midwives are bringing hope and healing
to those who need it the most
since 2012 they've helped bring down the
child mortality rate here
by almost 50 it is a powerful Testament
to the work of midwives everywhere and a
reminder of just what can be achieved
through education and a commitment to
improving the lives of others Angus back
to you now in the studio
[Applause]
thanks very much Angus well
that was Angus Harvey there reporting on
everything from everywhere all at once
and now to Science and Technology and
what many say is not just the biggest
news story of the year but perhaps the
most important technological
breakthrough
of our lifetimes chat
GPT
has taken the World by storm
becoming the quickest technology uptake
in human history
the power of artificial intelligence is
incredible but there are also very real
reasons to be concerned about its effect
on systems of power and its impact on
jobs and society as we wrestle with
these dilemmas though let us not forget
that in the last 12 months Humanity has
repeatedly shown our resilience
inventiveness
our capacity for expanding our knowledge
and ability to and to rise to meet our
greatest challenges
nine months ago
we received the first images from the
golden honeycomb 18 beryllium mirrors
of the James Webb Telescope unlocking
new secrets from the furthest reaches of
the cosmos
seven months ago we smashed a spacecraft
into an asteroid and altered its orbit
confirming a new found ability to create
planetary defense systems against
earth-bound objects
four months ago
we used freaking laser beams
to recreate the conditions inside of a
star achieving more energy out of a
nuclear fusion reaction than we put in
it's a milestone in our quest to provide
clean Limitless and affordable energy
and then just days later
scientists in London announced that they
had used a new form of crispr called
base editing to hotwire immune cells and
clear the body of a 13 year old girl
named Alyssa from an incurable form of
leukemia
it's an incredible medical breakthrough
the first use of a revolutionary new
type of treatment that may go on to save
millions of lives in the future
so why is it then that outside medical
and scientific circles almost nobody has
heard that story
why
are we so familiar with all of the
stories that make us feel scared or sad
or angry
but so many of these stories come to us
as a surprise
why are we so good at reporting bad news
but so bad at reporting good news
that question is something that I spend
a lot of time thinking about
I'm the editor of the future crunch
newsletter we share stories of progress
and what I've learned after eight years
of doing this work is that progress is
never a straight line
far too many still suffer in poverty
from disease and are trapped by conflict
the struggle for equality the fight for
justice continues in so many places in
the world we still have so much work to
do to to get done
we know that geopolitical tensions are
rising
climate change is genuinely scary and we
are still destroying too many parts of
our planet
but when we only tell the stories of
Doom we fail to see the stories
of possibility the hundreds of examples
of progress in human rights Rising
living standards Public Health victories
clean energy breakthroughs
technological magic ecological
restoration
and the countless extraordinary acts of
kindness that take place on this planet
every day
I believe that if we want to change the
story of the human race in the 21st
century we have to start changing the
stories that we tell ourselves
and we have to remember that hope isn't
a noun
it's a verb it's not something that we
have or something that we're given
it's something that we do
millions of people around the world
chose to Hope
in the last 12 months and then rolled up
their sleeves to get it done
perhaps it's time for the rest of us to
do the same
thank you
I'm Angus Harvey and let's make this the
news
foreign
[Applause]